de façon au pire et aux mets les plus
mauvais ou plus beau au meilleur mais
vous les animateurs on avait compris la
province et non une rhétorique présente
quel est selon vous le ou la meilleure
de cette année alors évidemment le
meilleur animateur
j'avais pensé aux patrons après je me
suis dit ça fait quand même un petit peu
à force de l'espace wen en main peut
donc je me suis dit que cette dame elle
est plutôt pas mal
on est d'accord pas mal par karine le
marchand et pourtant j'aime pas
nécessairement les programmes qu'elle
présente c'est vous dire combien je peux
être objective je la trouve talentueuse
je la trouve frêche je la trouve drôle
je trouve qu'elle a beaucoup d'esprit et
de second degré et quand on voit j'ai vu
le mot voilà c'est ça beaucoup mais
énormément
et quand on voit que même par rapport à
surtout quand on est femme dans ce
milieu c'est pas évident quand on a
traversé des choses et que c'est fait de
façon publique
elle garde la tête froide elle garde la
tête haute j'aime énormément ce qu'elle
incarne donc cmapress et bien le résumé
de karine en images ce matin le droit de
ne pas aimer ce que je fais ta laura
désir ce que tu veux contre moi mais tu
appelleras d'inventer des choses il ya
quelque chose qui revient toujours quand
tu perds quand tu parles de claire
chazal s'est tue dix jours elle est
comme ma mère et je sais que tu as perdu
ta mère et je pense que tu as fait un
transfert
ce que dit ya plein de gens qui sont
virés tous les jours on n'en fait pas
tout un drame et moi cette fille je
savais que la chose a été très touché
par tout ça moi c'est mon ami je l' ai
défendu mais moi quand je défends
quelqu'un c'est pas pour autant que je
vais attaquer ou inventer sur la
personne qui les avait un juge ne veut
pas ces jeux de la télévision mais mais
parfois tu es une caricature de toi même
et je crois que ce serait mieux si tu
étais dans dans le temps ta vérité j'ai
tapé beaucoup parce que parce que tu
m'avais fait mal et que du coup luc
angers quand j'aime les gens je les
défends kit est parfois un peu de
mauvaise foi ce que j'ai été et sur
cette partie là je m'en excuse pas
[Applaudissements]
et pas tout à fait un résumé du si le
gars il connaît très bien
c'est un beau moment de vérité et karine
le marchand c'est bien aussi parce que
je trouve que bien sûr elle est
talentueuse comme animatrice mais c'est
aussi une femme qui dit ce qu'elle pense
il n'y a pas de double visage ça c'est
très intéressant surtout très
appréciable de beau de voir matthieu
delormeau qui pour une fois 17,5 en ce
qu'il pense et qui s'excuse alors que je
me permets de dire ça je pense le bien
connaître c'est très rare qui est excusé
c'est d'autant plus appréciable je pense
ça va mieux les bus d'ailleurs ans en
sommes et nous c'est une grande histoire
d'accord mais ça va ça va ça s'en vient
ça l'arrivée avait été très largement
critiquée à propos de ces postures dans
son émission sur le canapé donc elle a
beaucoup d'humour
elle est même fait une parodie regarder
mais bien sûr mais je rêve mais oui il
est dingue dingue de moi comme tout le
monde d'ailleurs
mais dingue mais match sur tapis trafic
bonjour on va vous est fait dans études
c'est bien c'est jusqu'à qu'un de ses
importants la télévision quand même
engagé au cul alors le pire alors je
m'excuse d'avancé auprès de la personne
c'est un grand footballeur ça l'a été en
tout cas mais en animateur présentateur
ambianceur entertainer je suis désolé
mais pour l'ensemble de son oeuvre
c'est pas possible près david ginola on
lui donne des costumes beaucoup trop
grand prime time sur m6 ont valu en
remettra encore aux côtés d'eric antoine
durant les sessions secrètes voilà pour
édition secrète c'est juste pas possible
il est pas encore animateur il faut
qu'il ait plus de bouteille il faut
qu'on laisse faire ses armes mais là
c'est juste infernal pas pour moi on
peut critiquer les choix des autres
non mais je respecte mais là c'est
n'importe quoi des jeux viendront mettre
des pancartes inquiète c'est pour dire
de telles conneries ginola a fait
quelques émissions mais vous le flinguer
alors que c'est quelqu'un en
construction juste l'un des trous béants
quand il est en construction
la dengue et c'est pas le ps puis battus
et vous après aussi agi librement mais
ya mille fois pire que j'aie nolife
abondamment il est beau choquée alors
moi je commence par celle que j'aime pas
cette année c'est christina cole
tu ne vois pas ce que tu es en colère je
trouve que sos champion ou pas c'est
toujours pareil c'est caricatural mais
n'a pas cédé au risque de vous blesser
christina ça y est change de mots
magnifiques c'est fini passe à autre
chose
je pense que la chose que tu peux pas
dire sur christina cordula c'est à dire
qu'elle fait tout le temps la même chose
la preuve est de faire et non elle vient
de faire un nouveau point que l'émission
mariage
on voyait un pan de son s'il faut quatre
à un autre accent ça va être compliqué
cet accent nibles faut quatre charmantes
4,7 change non aux mêmes ne sont pas
mariés autres chats mal fatigué j'en ai
marre j'ai envie de passer à autre chose
j'ai envie d'une autre icône de la mode
en france et je trouve qu'elle a une
place il écoute aussi parce que au
niveau télé elle représente pas la bonne
humeur et surtout de lui reproche de
faire un truc qui sait le mieux faire
mais c'est une voie qui est choisie
détenus des fois je trouvais ça alors
quand socialiser quoi [ __ ] et cagole
jusqu'au bout de 12 mois magazine
voilà civile ben oui parce que ça fait
huit ans que ça existe ça fait huit ans
qu'il est numéro 1 ça fait huit ans
qu'ils luttent qui bossent qui se remet
en question qui à la concurrence
aujourd'hui est
[Applaudissements]
sera t pmp ou pâté pmp que je sois là ou
pas je m'excuse mais on peut pas dire un
truc c'est que c'est le seul qui donne
une place aux personnes victimes d'un
handicap au niveau de la télévision
française encense c'est le seul qui
s'associeront papa alors au cas où vous
ne connaîtrez pas le garçon voici
quelques images de cette émission va
être folle à l'avancé que les plus
grands puisque est dense et déjà dans
les grottes de la stone tous y aille
sochaux
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire c'est pas du tout mon
délire elle a même préparé l'émission
est quoi trop bien et tu préparé seuls
les professionnels
c'était pour moi et mon incroyable
talent
[Applaudissements]
alors cette saison j'ai été déçu par
l'animateur préféré des français
apparemment c'est michel cymes l'accord
tué récemment je suis retombé sur le
magazine de la santé ça fait vingt ans
au moins qu'ils les mains un temps et
trouver alger sans aucune énergie on les
aime bien pour pour ses vannes on le
retrouve souvent dans le bêtisier ça
c'est cool et sur le reste tous les
prime time il a animé en direct ont été
des fours et les faux seins que soit
laventure de médecine mais à chaque fois
c'est pas considéré par france 2 comme
des fours parce que il s'est renouvelée
à chaque fois son seul espoir c'est son
nouveau talk-show parlé hier en deuxième
partie de soirée
et là il va pas vers donné mon nom mais
maxime tu peux pas dire que c'est le
flop alors que tu viens de dire toi même
qu'il a un nouveau talk show qui prend
une nouvelle place dans la télévision de
soufre et que forcément il ya quelque
chose de mal à fédérer en prime ça pas
été jours au lit alors on va compter là
on ne sait pas son métier n'oubliez pas
juste moi je trouve qu'il est très très
tôt rouet et un pour arriver là où il en
est aujourd'hui franchement chapeau
ça fait 20 ans que les la télévision en
même temps et puis on va pas se mentir
s'ils continuent à faire des femmes
c'est parce qu'il a la carte auprès de
la dore et qu'elle veut continuer à
gawker
il n'oppose pas moi patrick dont
seulement imaginer des jeux en plateau
d'ailleurs que tout le monde a son mot à
dire et renouveler la soie la voilà des
mois et il est capable de 2000 et
d'incarner des jeux d'aventuré comme
fort boyard et pour l'avoir vu sur le
terrain c'est quelqu'un de très humble
et ça fait vraiment plaisir de le voir
aujourd'hui a été les faits marquants
qu'en parler les gens autour ni n'écoute
pas ses mots c'est là où il est beau
gosse mais surtout et des trop mignon
maxime gainey c'est ça on dit rien on ne
dit pas que c'est si une personne c'est
pas dans le lagon de la sentence et les
kills à 99 sa boulimie ces machines à
laver des fonds ce niveau il va passer
de bonnes vacances
merci à vous pour se battre alors j'ai
gardé le meilleur c'est stéphane plaza
logement il n'a pas de rival franchement
il est authentique
il est drôle il a transcendé
l'immobilier des qui fait quelque chose
ça marche il est formidable
vous n'êtes pas d'accord benjamin
castaldi made you die aliouane alan wake
up comme ça mais j'en suis là c'est pas
grave c'est le célèbre au moins le
meilleur animateur de la saison il doit
arrêter
non mais soyons honnêtes a ajouté bart
et invitations ça devrait franchir
besoin d'écouter quelque chose je
regarde jury les bombes il est bon mais
bon il fait d un super score il est
l'enjeu bien sur les ménagères sa dette
a casté pour vous propose depuis hier
vous avez certainement le pire
vous connaissez son surnom d'une
émission un flop
dès qu'ils touchent quelque chose ça se
casse la gueule mais bon y'a pas pire
vous acharnez ceci c'est moi c'est que
les chiffres 1 elle prend les chiffres
je regarde dit je parle jamais des gens
humainement c'est pas le problème
il est extrêmement respectable c'est là
il revient et qu'il avait là des coeurs
brisés la villa tiendra quatre jours
maintenant qu'il ya 80 deux épisodes
vous tombe également souhaité la saison
plus qu à nîmes a augmenté d'une saison
à l'autre a alors mené les jets et bien
pas bien mais des ruines azahaf où j'en
ai pas plus
madame c'est à vous alors et moi j'aime
pas critiquer franchement je suis mal
placé de schématiser voilà je fais moi
je me suis juste fait chier avec daphné
bürki mersin formidable cette fille
maintenance dans son dans l'émission je
me suis ennuyé j'ai décroché au bout de
trois minutes donc voilà je pense que
c'est pas la bonne chaussure pour elle
une manière très mal j'aime bien je veux
pas penser moi le sexe
bah oui j'adore et alors risqué mais
ouais all alone ont toujours pas compris
mais bon bref nous allons passer ce
match aller donc parler de ceux de mon
animateurs préférés je suis à deux
doigts de changer d'avis alors c'est qui
aimait ses lectrices il s'est plutôt les
benjamins c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
voilà non mais vraiment je t'aime
oui mais tu n'es pas tu n'es pas
objectif mais on va dire que je ne suis
pas objet pensez vous quand même je vais
dire quand même je vais fait dire
quelque chose tu est extrêmement bon
c'est vrai là je pense que tu avais eu à
venir au japon les deux meilleurs et
commença en six visites en france je
pense quand même que tu es un des
meilleurs animateurs mais toujours
rêveur j'aurais préféré que ce soit
gilles qui disent ça mais venant ton jeu
mais c'est ce que je leur ai dit mon
fort c'est à dire toi parce que c'est
faux vous alors émis avant alors écoutez
fait écouter c'est bientôt la fin eh
bien il reste contenu des missions on
fait ce qu'on veut mais bon on va
commencer avec le meilleur parce que je
crois que tout le monde serait d'accord
il peut à la fois nous présenter koh
lanta et il est génial il nous présente
le foot il est génial il fait le mag
il a ramené des idées en plus parce que
la réalité virtuelle
c'est lui qui a pensé quand même voilà
il l'a vu aux états unis il a voulu que
ça en france il le fait très très bien
j'ai trouvé d'une classe folle quand ya
eu toute cette histoire de supposée
agression sexuelle sur le tournage de
koh lanta il a été nickel du début à la
fin
c'est un mec extraordinaire ce quelqu'un
de très sympa et ça l'animateur génial
voilà je pense qu'on est tous des
valides
ouais on peut l'acquérir
c'est quelqu'un de bien et obtient à
will appear
ah bah non mr ça c'est tu disais très
sobre vendée qui présente un truc
s'assure déjà c'est faux mais lui pareil
mais c'est un enfer sarc aidés qui fait
imprègne tu peux être sûr que tu fais
pas 10% et en plus j'aime pas la façon
dont il fait là dans les amours à mettre
des petits tacles de temps en temps à
theix je vois pas l'intérêt c'est bon
texte il a été viré on a bien compris tu
as récupéré le truc tu es content mais
il y en a mais des petits tacles je vois
pas le voilà qui a déserté les amours
autant ben oui j'y crois
il a un grand chose dans les amours et
il faut des tacles à theix et je trouve
que c'est pas classe du tout facile à
dire production alors que ces pierres
gemmes et des claques à theix ou des
taxes à tout monsieur les dix événements
qui ont marqué cette année
j'allais dire sur vous un cas parce que
j'allais dire l'inscription à bâtir
comment voulez vous je le sache et ou
même parce qu'on sait pas de pancarte
excuses vous laissez faire en spontané
je me dire le pire parce qu'on s'en fout
je suis pas là pour cracher sur personne
et toute façon si je commençais à dire
du mal du tout ce que je pense qu'on
serait là encore demain en revanche
c'est sûr vous benjamin moi je vous ai
connu je vous ai connu à la télé j'ai
grandi avec vous je vous ai connu après
où vous étiez mon mentor j'ai évolué
avec vous et je suis franchement
agréablement surprise de l'humilité que
vous avez parce que vous étiez je le dis
à l'époque de secret story tv voilà vous
étiez le number one quand vous voyez on
bégayait j'en suis même tombé dans les
escaliers sur le plateau vous en
souvenez et je suis fan de ce que vous
êtes aujourd'hui parce que quand on est
un grand
on n'a rien besoin de prouver on reste
toujours au retour à la maison
je le dis et je le pense sincèrement
et vous savez je suis pas langue de bois
vous me connaissez non pas lors de bois
sage aujourd'hui voilà donc franchement
j'aime excusez moi pour moi number one
et voilà c'est fait